est tout de suite place à notre second
débat que nous consacrons ce soir à
l'Iran depuis les attaques du Hamas le 7
octobre dernier la communauté
internationale a les yeux rivé sur la
République islamique on sait que le
régime de Mola est un grand financier un
grand soutien sans faille de tous les
ennemis d'Israël et on sait que l'Iran a
été aussi fragilisé par de fortes
tensions sociales et que l'Iran
justement vient de connaître aussi la
semaine dernière sur son sol un double
attentat meurtrier on fait tout de suite
le point sur la situation là-bas avec
Jérôme rab
l'Iran est secoué par l'attentat le plus
meurtrié sur son sol depuis plus de 40
ans par le bilan bien sûr plus de 90
morts mais surtout par ceux qui l'ont
revendiqué l'État islamique organisation
terroriste sunite qui depuis plusieurs
années vise la puissance numéro 1 de
l'Islam chiit car cette attaque
intervient alors que l'Iran tente de
normaliser ses relation avec les autres
puissances régionales preuve en est
depuis le 1er janvier l'Iran a rejoint
en même temps que l'Arabie Saoudite le
nouveau format élargi des bricks cette
organisation des pays d' émergents mené
par le Brésil la Russie l'Inde la Chine
et l'Afrique du Sud une manière de
rompre son isolement international
l'Iran cherche maintenant à stabiliser
le jeu et à se rapprocher de l'Arabie
Saoudite l'attentat de daesh contre
soleimman akermon rappelle de vieilles
histoires mais c'est peut-être un moyen
hélas dramatique de remettre les choses
en place et que Iran Arabie Saoudite
règle
autour d'une table et non plus dans des
attentats le relation passé difficile si
d'un côté l'Iran joue la normalisation
avec ses voisins il n'abandonne pas son
identité révolutionnaire islamique en se
posant en première ennemi d'Israël
multipliant ses soutiens dans la région
du Hamas palestinien auzbollah libanais
en passant par les rebelles outil au
Yémen ces derniers sont d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui les plus visibles depuis la
pointe sud de la péninsule arabique il
menace le commerce international is
visant les bateau qui passent par la mer
Rouge derrière ces attaques aucun doute
pour les États-Unis c'est l'Iran qui
montre son pouvoir de
nuisance ces attaques ont été soutenu et
encouragé par l'Iran en terme de
technologie d'équipement de
renseignement et
d'information certains parlent d'une
stratégie de diversion iranienne qui
freine lezbollah au Liban d'un côté dans
sa réplique face à Israël mais encourage
par ailleurs les outils au Yémen pour ne
pas apparaître faible un double jeu qui
montre pour ce spécialiste le dilemme
iranien la crise actuelle est une crise
existentielle pour la République
islamique soit elle réussi à résoudre
ces contradictions entre une puissance
régionale forte et pacifique ou une une
puissance révolutionnaire qui privilégie
l'axe du l'axe de la résistance à la
construction nationale et ce dilemme il
est présent sur la table des Iraniens et
du gouvernement iranien tous les jours
un gouvernement fragilisé aussi par les
fractures dans la société depuis plus
d'un an et 3 mois maintenant des femmes
en particulier et plus largement la
jeunesse récl la fin du régime islamique
avec comme slogan femme vie liberté un
mouvement qui tient dans la durée malgré
la féroce répression qui s'abat sur les
contestataires le jeu trouble de l'Iran
on en parle ce soir avec mes invités
bonsoir am Chell bonsoir vous êtes
iranologue membre du programme RTI alors
c'est erti pour écosystème religieux et
territoire identitaire c'est un
programme à l'université Sorbonne
Nouvelle Paris 3 et vous êtes auteur
d'un livre qui va s'appeler enfin qui
s'appelle déjà le corant dans le sang
mais qui va paraître le corant 200 s
voilà mais qui va paraître le mois
prochain aux éditions du SER avocôté
Thierry Coville bonsoir vous êtes
spécialiste de l'Iran chercheur à l'Iris
l'Institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques et puis auteur de l'Iran
une puissance en mouvement aux éditions
Erol cette fois-ci et puis enfin Armine
Arfi grand au point auteur de un
printemps à than qui était paru chez
plomb et puis bien sûr th tranui qui
m'accompagne jusqu'à la fin de cette
émission on va commencer sur sur ce
double attentat du 3 janvier est-ce
qu'on est certaintain est-ce qu'on peut
dire de façon certaine qui est derrière
ce double attentat à Kerman et pourquoi
Amell alors déjà le dernier attentat le
dernier double attentat ce qui est une
stratégie régulièrement daesi hein qui
avait eu lieu en 2017 en juin 2017 en
Iran avait eu la particularité d'être
revendiqué par deux groupes différents
et puis ensuite un un faisceau d'indice
rendait quasiment incontournable l'idée
selon laquelle daesh était derrière
alors on peut rappeler de mémoire ce
double attentat céit à la fois devant le
parlement iranien et au mosolé de roméie
et au mosolé de l'imam roméie tout à
fait double attentat une un peu plus de
10 morts me semble-t-il 17 morts et les
C personnes les cinq terroristes ét donc
revendiqué à l'époque par l'État
islamique et par un groupe
indépendantiste parce qu'il y a beaucoup
de groupe indépendantiste en Iran dont
on sait qu'il a une longue tradition
impériale avec plusieurs c'est une
mosaïque de peuple l'Iran 50 % de la
population est Perse exclusivement donc
et alors celui-là a été revendiqué par
le porte-parole officiel de l'État
islamique sur une boucle télégram oui
mais il faut pas oublier que
idéologiquement c'est ce qui peut faire
le plus plus sens il faut rappeler
l'histoire de daesh l'histoire de daesh
c'est celle d'une cissione avec Al-Qaïda
en Irak Al-Qaïda est un groupe qui
fonctionne de deux façons soit avec des
groupes membres c'est-à-dire qui sont
créés pour être Al-Qaïda avec des fonds
Al-Qaïda et des hommes Al-Qaïda soit des
groupes affiliés ou associés
c'est-à-dire des groupes djihadistes qui
ont des intérêts et des agendas locaux
mais qui faute de moyens à un moment
donné vont prêter allégance à Al-Qaïda
pour ce qui concerne l'Irak il y avait
Al-Qaïda en Irak qui devait suivre une
feuille de route internationale faisant
du croisé et du Juif la cible à
privilégié sauf que dans l'Irak des
années 2000 on a une majorité chiide
dans le pays 60 % de la population qui
prend sa revanche sur des décennies
d'oppression lié au gouvernement par
Saddam Hussein et on voit qu'assez
régulièrement Al-Qaïda en Irak commence
à se détourner de la cible
traditionnelle américaine notamment avec
les intérêts américain pour se mettre à
bombarder des cibles chiites jusqu'à
temps que le divorce soit consommé ça
s'appellera désormais état Islam enfin
ça va s'appeler état islamique en Irak
et puis après profitant du chaos syrien
voisin ce sera le daesh que nous
connaissons donc au départ daesh
contrairement à Al-Qaïda veut faire du
cheit sa cible privilégiée donc là on
est faut le rappeler pour nos
téléspectateurs sur le grand chisme
religieux classique j'allais dire
séculaire entre chit et sunnit là on est
on rappelle que l'Iran est un pays
clairement chiite et que l'État
islamique pardon est une organisation
sunite tiri c'est-à-dire qui excommunie
du giron de l'islam tous ceux qui n'ont
pas la même lecture que lui les chiites
au premier chef donc forcément l'Iran
est la cible privilégiée puisque non
seulement c'est le pays le plus beé en
chiite au monde proportionnellement et
aussi pour une simple et bonne raison
c'est qu'il a investi le rôle du chiisme
révolutionnaire et politique sous la
volonté d'une for
théocratique alors dans son communiqué
le porte-parole de l'État islamique il
fait allusion à la situation à Gaza h et
il dit la vraie nature de cette guerre
la guerre à Gaza et qu'elle fait partie
d'un axe imaginaire que l'Iran a créé au
service de ses projets afin d'impliquer
toutes les factions palestiniennes en
tant que mandataire de l'Iran mais
jamais l'inverse l'Iran et ses parties
ont été sauvé de la bataille féroce que
Gaza subit seul du sang de ses enfants
et de ses femmes autrement dit
thierikovit daesh reproche une forme de
double jeu à l'Iran vis-à-vis des
Palestiniens ou d'être pas assez
agressif avec Israël en fait parmi les
raisons qui ont poussé enfin ce qu'on
pense à cet attentat il y a
effectivement le caractère chide de
l'Iran à 90 %. le fait que l'Iran dans
la région et le pays qui a le plus lutté
militairement contre l'État islamique
avec rasem Soleimani donc c'est pas
hasard que l'attentat a lieu rppel que
l'attentat il a lieu le 3 janvier où on
célèbre on commémore la mort de euh du
général soleemani disparu enfin abattu 4
ans plus tôt par un drone américain
assassiné oui assassiné oui assassiné 4
ans plus tôt par un par un drone
américain et que ce général avait mené
notamment toutes les toutes les
opération militaire au nom des des
brigades iraniennes en Syrie en Irak
contre l'État islamique c'est lui qui a
franchement il se trouve était en Iran
l'été 2014 c'était un peu la panique
hein dans le nord de l'IRAC l'éta il
faut s'en rappeler quand même notamment
en en Occident quand l'État islamique
est passé de Syrie en Irak c'était la
panique donc si l'Iran et notamment
rassem solleimini n'avait pas été là
effectivement alors il y avait quelques
il y avait des conseillers iraniens on
sait qu'il y a des gens du hbolah qui
sont venus mais c'est surtout il a il a
organisé la résistance à partir des mili
chites des mili chites en Irak et
effectivement pour pour revenir à votre
question c'est pour l'État islamique
c'est un ennemi mortel parce que c'est
lui qui les a battu en Irak et en Syrie
ensuite hein parce que et donc la guerre
à Gaza évoquée par le porte-pole c'est
il y a aussi pour pour l'État islamique
clirence c'est le principal danger dans
la région et il pensent qu'il y a une
imposture effectivement à partir du
moment où il considère que c'est des
apostas c'est pas des vrais musulmans
ils sont ils sont vent debout furieux et
c'est ce qu'ils veulent dire parce mon
avis ce communiqué que que l'Iran prend
le rôle quelque part de défense des
musulmans à travers la guerre à Gaza
pour eux c'est une imposture je pense ce
qu'il veul dire et al arminefi on a
entendu aussi quelques responsables
iraniens pas les plus nombreux mais
quelques-uns quand même qui ont pointé
du doigt Israël et les Américains c'est
un grand classique euh oui c'est vrai
que c'est un grand classique d'abord le
le le guide suprême de la Révolution
d'ayatah al khamani qui a désigné les
ennemis de l'Iran d'habitude
deent ça signifie serraal et les
États-Unis et puis un conseiller du
Président Ibrahim Raissi ultra
conservateur qui a désigné lui
expressément Israël il faut savoir que
par la suite suite à la revendication
faite par le porte-parole de l'État
islamique par le biais des canaux
traditionnels de de lei euh le chef des
gardien de la révolution iranienne
l'armée idéologique du régime a persisté
signé d'une certaine manière en
affirmant que ce n'était peut-être pas
directement euh les États-Unis et les
siionistes qu'ils appellent donc les
sionistes à savoir les Israéliens mais
que ces derniers ont agi en permettant
justement au groupes djihadistes d'être
armé et financé bon il apparaît pour
l'instant que c'est complètement h hors
de de propos d'autant que encore une
fois pour avoir pour avoir échangé avec
d'ancien responsabl militaire israélien
il s'agit ça ne correspond pas du tout
ce type d'attaque comme le disait améie
Chelli avec deux bombes une justement
pour créer la panique et l'autre pour
provoquer un carnage lorsque les les les
ambulances les secours et les fidèles
sont en train de courir partout visent à
faire un nombre maximum de victimes ne
correspond pas du tout au l'habitude
qu'ont les Israéliens à savoir de mener
des assassinats en tout cas des
éliminations
ciblé oui on rappelle que c'est un
attentat qui a visé la population civile
qui a faitun centaine de morts je dis
tout à l'heure et plus de 300 du régime
et ce ne sont pas des assassinats ciblés
comme le pratique parfois le Mossad il
l' fait d'ailleurs en décembre derni
exactement contre un au responsables des
Gardiens de la révolution de la force
Crot donc la branche extérieure des g de
la révolution en Syrie certains Mousavi
d'ailleurs pour lequel l'Iran a promis
qu'il répondrait contre Israël aussi
bien directement que par le biais de ces
organisations qui lui sont allié à
savoir les milices chiit en Irak en
Syrie les yéénis les les rebelles outil
au Yémen ou le hbola au Liban alors Iran
Israël on le sait depuis plus de 40 ans
maintenant ce sont deux ennemis
historique j'allais dire 3 mois après
Thierry Coville est-ce qu'on en sait
plus sur le rôle qu'à joué l'Iran dans
les attaques du 7 octobre du Hamas en
Israël est-ce que on en sait plus sur le
on a parlé de soutien logistique de
matériel militaire est-ce qu'il y a eu
un soutien tactique est-ce que le rôle
de l'Iran a été précisé
alors moi je suis pas journaliste je
suis pas policier moi ce que je ve dire
là par du contexte non mais je veux
direon il y a des gens qui font plein de
supposition et cetera je pense qu'il a
eu quand même se référit je crois une
déclaration quelques jours après de donc
le guide Ali ramani donc le numéro 1 de
la République islamique d'Iran qui a dit
nous on quelque part on applaudit mais
c'est pas nous hein c'est c'est le
travail des des Palestiniens donc je
pense que du côté iranien ça a été très
clair que en gros ils n'ont pas
participé à cette action alors il y a eu
une sorte de polémique parce que
justement en préparation de de
l'anniversaire de de la mort rassem
Suleimani il y a un responsable des pass
d'Aran qui a dit euh cette attaque du 7
octobre pour nous est une
vengeance par rapport à l'assassinat
alors tout de suite tout le monde s'est
emballé et je crois que les pour c'est
en dilon sur effectivement c'est un
sujet sensible parce que le Hamage je
crois le lendemain a dit non non mais
l'Iran il n est pour rien et les passes
d'Aran est obligé de faire machine
arrière en disant mais on voulait dire
justement que c'est c'est cette cette
attaque qui est une une vengeance à à à
pour répondre à votre question oui ce
qu'on sait hein ce qu'on sait c'est que
oui l'Iran le Hamas est un un membre de
cet axe de résistance dont vous avez
parlé contre Israël oui l'Iran finance
le Hamas oui Ilir en forme sans doute on
le sait les combattants du Hamas qui
sont sans doute venus à Teran qui ont
subi une formation donc il y a il y a il
y a une concertation je veux dire vous
avez celui qui a pris la suite de rassem
Souleimani je crois qu' s'appelle Rani
il fait des il fait il a des visites
régulières dans toute la région et il
rencontre les leaders du Hamas les
leaders du Hezbollah donc il y a une
coordination c'est ce qu'on sait pour
l'instant on a plutôt l'impression que
c'est ça qui est un peu difficile à voir
c'est l'Iran a a nié toute implication
d'un autre côté on voit quand même une
grande coordination de cette axe de
résistance par rapport ce qui se passe
après si vous voulez donc pour répondre
vot question ce que je comprends de ce
que vous dites c'est que l'Iran n'était
pas donneur
d'ordre mais que l'Iran a peut-être
laissé faire c'est je pense que c'est
même allé trop loin on pour l'instant si
vous
voulez on peut pas dire que même que
l'Iran était au courant parce qu'il y a
même j'ai même entendu des analyses qui
me semble pas bête c'est que il y a y a
eu de telles fuites dans le système
sécuritaire iranien vous parliez des
attaques de Israël quand même qui sont
allés loin ont tué des gens il fallait
voir qu'il av beaucoup d'information la
faisait pas confiance c'est pas c'est je
veux dire ça me paraît rationnel que du
côté du H je pense qu'il y a eu 1
milliard de précautions pour ne pas
parler de cette affaire et notamment pas
le parler à l'Iran qui manifestement euh
cette information pouvait arriver aux
oreilles d'Israël donc pour répondre à
votre question pour l'instant l'Iran ni
toute implication ni ni est trop courant
si vous dire ni être au courant de cette
attaque par contre le Hamas fait partie
très clairement de l'axe de résistance
et et le s ils le soutiennent voilà
alors Amélie Chelly peut-être qu'on peut
expliquer à nos téléspectateurs puisquon
vient de parler de du chisme entre les
chites et les sunites pour pourquoi
l'Iran paysit soutiendrait un mouvement
sunit comme le Hamas c'est une
excellente question en règle générale
quand il y a des prises de décision ou
l'Iran est au premier au premier rang et
qu'il y a des prises de parole
extrêmement officielles de de membres de
la classe politique ou de mem membres de
la classe militaire en Iran assez
régulièrement on voit une myiade de
drapeau derrière l'intervenant cette
myade de drapeau c'est ce qu'ils
appellent l'axe de la murawama
c'est-à-dire l'axe de la résistance et
effectivement quand on observe ces
drapeaux le seul qui soit un drapeau
d'une milice non chiite c'est le Hamas
je je précise pour les tépectateurs
pardon le hzbollah par exemple parti
frèreit vous avez aussi les fun afghan
lesabun pakistanais le hashabi les milit
d'Irak dont on parlait tout à l'heure
alors ça n'empêche pas qu'il y ait dans
ces milices chiit des brigades qui ne
soient pas par exemple la Babylone est
une brigade chrétienne à l'intérieur
d'une milice chiite irakenne mais celle
qui est clairement à la fois sunnite et
donc qui dénote par rapport à émanation
des Frères musulmans et émanation de
Frères musulmans qui en règle générale
ne voit pas d'un très bon œil les chites
c'est tout le paradoxe de c'est le Hamas
c'est la raison pour laquelle d'ailleurs
qui joue à la guerre des dollars en
matière de financement du Hamas dans le
monde il y a d'une part l'Iran qui veut
investir de la façon la plus pleine et
entière qui soit le soft power
anti-israélien donc c'est au nom du
vieux principe les ennemis de mes
ennemis sont mes amis oui et de l'autre
côté vous avez le portefeuille
international du frérisme le Qatar
d'accord
armineifi depuis le 7 octobre tout le
monde a agité le spectre d'une escalade
en cas d'une implication directe de
l'Iran dans le conflit or il n'en a rien
été l'Iran n'a pas n'est pas entré
directement dans un conflit avec Israël
pourquoi ils le veulent pas au fond
parce qu'elle n'a pas intérêt ou à une
guerre conventionnelle contre contre son
ennemi toujours et ça rappelle une
certain et avec les Américains faut pas
oublier qu'au lendemain du 7 octobre les
Américains ont quand même dépêché en
Méditerranée orientale de porte-avion
même si l'un vient de rentrer dans sa
base pour pour enfin vient d'être
rappelé pour d'autres missions mais il y
a eu un effet dissuasif clair vis-à-vis
de l'Iran et du Hezbollah et de l'autre
l'Iran na pas intérêt encore une fois un
conflit direct et conventionnel avec
Israël faut pas oublier euh
l'élimination je voulais dire parce que
militairement ils sont ils sont moins
forts parce que militairement en tout
cas en terme de technologie en terme
d'aviation oui ils sont moins forts que
les Israéliens eux l'Iran ce qu'ils ont
toujours fait même si derrière ils ont
ils ont quand même un un programme
balistique qui est dissuasif et que
aujourd'hui c'est une puissance du seuil
nucléaire même s'ils n'ont pas d'après
les services de renseignements
occidentaux la bombe atomique mais
l'Iran a toujours agi de façon on va
dire par le biais de ses proxy dans la
région souvenez-vous lors de les proxis
on rappelle que c'est des factions
factions ch qui lui sont affilié donc
dont on vient exactement de parler
d'ailleurs c'est par ce biais là que
l'Iran a répondu mais souvenez-vous par
exemple de l'élimination de rassem
Soleimani donc par une frappe de drone
américain ordonné par Donald Trump en
janvier 2020 l'Iran a a fait attention
de
réagir en visant une base irakienne où
se se trouvaient les soldats américains
mais en prenant le SO en préalable
d'avertir les iraakiens qui ont à leur
tour averti les Américains pour que il
n'y ait aucun mort aujourd'hui l'Iran
n'a aucun intérêt à un conflit direct ni
avec les Américains vu la puissance de
frappe dont il bénéficie par le billet
de ses porteavion ni même vis-à-vis
d'Israël d'ailleurs au passage le
Hezbollah libanais qui est aujourd'hui
le principal succès de de l'exportation
de cette révolution islamique depuis
1979 sert principalement de dissuasion
pour éviter que les Israéliens un jour
et l'idée de frapper les sites
nucléaires iraniens on sait que cette
question inquiète grandement des
Israéliens d'avoir justement un pays qui
a juré leur perte et qui est en sur le
point de se doter de la bombe donc
l'Iran a davantage agi par le biais donc
de ses alliés deaxe de la résistance on
en a parlé le hbolla Libanais les
rebelles utsi en mer Rouge qui ont visé
le territoire israélien mais également
des groupes des mil chiites en Syrie
tout en veillant à ne pas perdre son
principal allié le Hezbolla à savoir que
on a aujourd'hui un conflit de basse
intensité mais qui a quand même fait à
la frontière nord d'Israël et donc au
Sud Liban pas moins de
165 victimes de la part du hzbollah cinq
côté israélien euh d'avantage des des
soldats quel est le degré d'autonomie de
de de ces factions de ces proxis comme
vous dites parce que on le voit le le
hbola est sur une position j'allais dire
de de retenue mais en tout cas ils font
très attention à ce que l'escalade ne
monte pas trop fort on a l'impression
que les outils en revanche sont dans une
agression plus caractérisée plus plus
plus mécanique il y a déjà eu 26 euh
bateaux attaqués je crois dans ce qu'on
voit en mer Rouge on a l'impression
d'assista la répétition de ce qui s'est
passé en 2019 dans lestroit d'ormous euh
donc dans le Golf Persique où l'Iran 1
an après avoir euh attendu en vain que
les Européens essayent de sauver
l'accord sur le nucléaire a commencé à
saboter des navires des terss pour faire
monter la pression et pousser
l'administration Trump à euh des
compromis ce qui ne s'est pas produit
mais en tout cas pour lui faire payer
prix ça veut dire que chacun fait ce
qu'il veut chacun de ses groupes a quand
même une capacité d'autonomie par
rapport évid bien évidemment que par
rapport oui oui par rapport à l'Iran
bien évidemment après sur certaines
décisions stratégiques par exemple le
fait de ne pas rentrer dans un conflit
direct je pense que l'Iran a son mot à
dire de la même de même sorte que l'Iran
euh aujourd'hui euh voilà veille à à ce
que euh en tout cas sur des questions
aussi importantes le le hzbolah n'entre
pas dans la danse maintenant dans chacun
de ces pays et l'Iran insiste là-dessus
ces différents groupes ont leur degré
d'autonomie le hzbolah par exemple
aujourd'hui est la milice la plus
puissante au Liban sans laquelle rien ne
se fait dans le pays du Sadan quand on
dit l'Iran amé Chelli c'est une
république islamique qui décide au fond
c'est le guide suprême c'est le
président de la République c'est le chef
des armées alors constitutionnellement
c'est le guide suprême le guide suprême
a un droit de regard sur tout et s'il
n'est pas à l'origine de certaines
décisions en fonction de ce qui est
constitutionnellement prévu il a un
droit de vetto au moins donc
constitutionnellement c'est lui
maintenant on s'est rendu compte
notamment à l'ône des derniers mandats
de Hassan Rouhani donc celui qui était
là avant l'actuel Président Ibrahim
Raisi qu'il y avait quand même des
contre-points mais qui avait laav du
guide néanmoins c'est-à-dire des
dissonances discursives qui pouvait
alors à côté d'un discours extrême avec
une rhétorique extrêmement
traditionnelle de la République
islamique anti-israélienne
anti-américaine ou autre avoir des
discours beaucoup plus modérés beaucoup
plus en phase avec le langage des
relations internationales et des
négociations diplomatiques du côté de la
classe politique mais
constitutionnellement ça reste le guide
il est la clé de vooute de tout le
système c'est un système qui s'appelle
le système du veloyat etfari
c'est-à-dire de la tutelle du juriste
théologien le juriste théologien c'est
le guide suprême il est censé être
hayatah enfin il est hayatollah on en a
connu deux jusqu'à présent celui qui a
mis en place la République islamique
donc entre 79 et 89 c'est jù la romini
et depuis
aliam et normalement il faut attendre
que celui-là décède pour en voir arriver
un nouveau constitutionnellement du
alors il il y a un terrain en tout cas
où l'Iran et Israël se mèneent une
véritable guerre même j'allais dire
plutôt une véritable C bergerre comme va
nous le raconter Alexandre
Poussard bonsoir Alexandre bonsoir
Mathieu bonsoir à
tous Alors je le disais l'Iran et Israël
se font déjà la guerre en fait
effectivement sur une guerre
cybernétique effectivement une guerre
sur le terrain du cyberespace qui est
plutôt intense he depuis l'attaque du 7
octobre en décembre dernier un groupe de
hackurs iranien proche des Gardiens de
la révolution s'est infiltré dans le
système informatique de l'hôpital Ziv
dans le Nord d'Israël et cette attaque
et bien elle a permis de rendre publ des
milliers de dossiers médicaux personnels
cette attaque elle n'en revanche pas
perturbé le fonctionnement de cet
hôpital important qui devait faire face
à l'afflux de soldats Israëliens blessés
à Gaza alors la Rost israélienne ne
s'est pas fait attendre le 18 décembre
un groupe de hackurs israéliens
surnommés les moineau prédateur a réussi
à paralyser 70 % des stations servic en
Iran impossible à ce moment-là pour les
Iraniens de payer par carte bancaire
leur plein de carburant ce groupe de
hackur les moineau prédateurs il y a il
a des liens très étroits avec les
services de renseignement de l'État
hébreu he selon les médias israéliens et
c'est à cœur il n'hésite pas à
communiquer à revendiquer leurs actes
regarder leur message après la paralysie
des stations services iraniennes notre
attaque vient en réponse à la guerre
mené par la République islamique et ses
alliés dans la région contre Israël Ali
rameni le guide suprême de la révolution
doit apprendre que jouer avec le feu à
un prix fin de citation à noter que le
gouvernement israélien n'a pas commenter
cette cyberataque d'ampleur contre
l'Iran mais les autorités de l'État
hébreux dénombrent depuis le début de la
guerre une 4antaine de tentatives de
cyber attaque venant d'Iran et visant
les données sensibles de nombreuses
entreprises israéliennes mais ce qu'on
peut dire aussi c'est que cette cyber
guerre elle a commencé bien avant les
attaques du du 7 octobre oui les
hackeurs israéliens ont déjà frappé fort
contre l'Iran ces dernières années en
2022 le groupe des moineaux prédateurs a
revendiqué une explosion dans une
Assyrie en Iran ainsi qu'une tentative
de sabotage du réseau ferroviaire
iranien et puis déjà une attaque des
stations service d'Iran en 2021 et puis
du côté iranien en 2020 des hackers s'en
était pris à la compagnie nationale des
eaux israéliennes en tentant d'augmenter
le taux de chlore dans les stations
dépuration pour rendre l'eau non non
potable une attaque qui avait été déjoué
au dernier moment par Israël qui avait
alors répliqué par une cyberataque
massive paralysant les ports iraniens
donc après une acalmie sur ce tirain sur
ce terrain cyber dans la première moitié
de l'année 2023 et bien la cyber guerre
est relancée entre l'Iran et Israël bien
merci beaucoup Alexandre je voudrais
qu'on aborde maintenant un chapitre
diplomatique plus géopolitique j'allais
dire Thierry Coville est-ce que l'Iran
est en train de sortir de son isolement
sur la scène internationale
oui oui alors c'est très clairement
alors il faut faut bien distinguer du
fait de de la sortie de Donald Trump de
l'accord sur nucléaire en mai 2018 je
pense que c'est la clé pour c'est pour
ça que ça va mal avec les pays
occidentaux parce que Trump les
États-Unis ont ré imposé des sanctions
contre les États-Unis et les Européens
contre excm contre l'Iran et les
Européens n'ont rien fait pour contrer
ces sanctions donc on on voit bien que
les pour et pour un certain nom d'utes
raisons donc les les les relations sont
on va dire quasiment catastrophiques
avec tout le bloc occidental oui en va
l'Europe et les
États-Unis par contre c'est vrai que
alors face à cette situation les
dirigeants iraniens ils ont pas trop le
choix l'Iran est une puissance ça date
c'est pas nouveau une puissance
régionale moyenne qui a besoin de
soutien de superpissance notamment des
des pays qui on qui ont un rôle dans le
Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
donc ils se sont tournés très
naturellement vers la Chine et la Russie
idéologiquement ceux qui dirigent l'Iran
c'est les factions les plus radicales
donc ça ça ça va ça va dans leur sens
donc effectivement on voit très bien il
y a vraiment un rapprochement avec la
Chine alors il y a cet accord surtout
avec Pékin plus alors non la Russie
aussi alors c'est un peu différent je
pense qu'avec la Chine il y a quand même
un accord de de 25 ans signé en 2005
2016 qui on sait pas trop ce qu'il y a
dedans mais en gros un accord de de 25
ans avec la Chine c'est pas un aun il y
a des un domaine militaire des
infrastructures l'Iran attend beaucoup
desinvestissements chinois notamment
pour faire partie de la route de la soie
dans l'énergie dans l'économie donc
c'est un énorme accord et on voit on n
pas trop d'information là-dessus mais on
voit très bien que c'est c'est assez
discret la cette coopération se met en
place avec la Russie je pense que c'est
c'est plus récent c'est très clairement
avec ce qui s avec la guerre en Ukraine
on voit alors en gros alors il y a un
débat en Iran c'est que un certain
nombre d'Iraniens ont l'impression
qu'ils sont un peu été attirés un petit
peu dans dans dans le piège russe parce
que d'un côté ben les Russes ont demandé
des drones iraniens donc l'Iran alors
l'Iran a livré ses drones l'Iran se
retrouve allié alors allier dé facto de
la de la Russie et euh il y a également
l'idée de préparer un plan de 25 ans de
nouveau sur le modèle euh chinois on
peut rappeler que les relations entre
les deux pays étaient pas franchement
euh on peut rappeler que les relations
entre les deux pays avant était pas
franchement eu si si alors la la Russie
la Russie il y a quand même une alliance
euh quand même assez objective on va
dire stratégique entre la Russie et
l'Iran pour un certain nombre de raisons
il y a eu la guerre en Syrie quand même
militairement euh d'ailleurs c'est
rassem Souleimani qui veut négocier avec
Poutine et et c'est les passes d'Aran
les Iraniens et l'armée russe qui s'alli
pour soutenir Bachar el-Assad alors du
côté russe il voit on revient à ce qu'on
parlait la différence sunichite il voit
la l'Iran comme un barrage contre
l'extrémisme sunite donc l'Iran est très
important pour eux et et du côté iranien
on en revient à cette idée c'est qu'ils
ont besoin d'un soutien d'un pays membre
du Conseil de sécurité des Nations unies
la Russie a quand même jouer un rôle
très important ils sont pas d'accord
pour que l'Iran et la bombe atomique
mais ils ont toujours dit faut régler
cette question par la négociation donc
cétait vraiment vent debout contre la
stratégie américaine alors on voit
l'émergence d'un nouvel axe diplomatique
et ce qu'il a peut-être aussi un nouvel
axe économique puisqu'on sait que l'Iran
on l'a appris depuis le sommet de de
Johannesburg va intégrer les bricks
alors les bricks sont rappelle hein que
c'est ce groupe constitué par le Brésil
la Russie l'Inde la Chine l'Afrique du
Sud et qui va s'élargir cette année à
des pays supplémentaires dont l'Égypte
l'Arabie Saoudite les Émirats et puis
notamment l'Iran c'est une une victoire
ire diplomatique encore pour l'Iran ou
c'est une vraie opportunité économique
je dirais que c'est une coïncidence avec
un esprit iranien qui a toujours eu un
esprit Brix de non alignement et
d'économie qui contourne justement degé
ou de force le dollar étant donné les
sanctions donc il y a cette chosel après
économiquement la on parle assez
régulièrement de pivot vers l'est quand
il s'était agis même avant cette
question des bricks de d'accord avec la
Chine mais aussi avec la Russie il faut
pas oublier que pour ce contournement
des sanctions on a des stratégies
notamment bancaires qui se mettent en
place depuis pas mal d'années maintenant
avec la Russie des accords qui
permettent encore une fois de
contourner l'extraterritorialité des
sanctions par des des des des man on
peut rappeler que ce dont rêvent les
Iraniens c'est d'une économie qui soit
dédollarisée d'une certaine façon
puisque il y a des sanctions depuis 4
ans c'est surtout que ils ont pas trop
le choix au départ quand il y a eu les
accords sur le nucléaire de signer
c'était aussi une façon de pouvoir se
tourner vers l'ouest et vers la qualité
la qualité qui n'était pas quelque chose
de coextensif à la Chine du point de vue
des Iraniens et notamment pour ce qui
concerne tout ce qui relève du médical
c'estàd que les iraniens avaient grand
besoin de pouvoir se donner les moyens
d'avoir accès aux médicaments produits
par l'Occident redoutant la qualité des
médicaments asiatiques euh c'est ce qui
revient très régulièrement dans sur les
chaînes notamment de la de la de
l'opposition iranienne quand vous avez
des téléspectateurs qui peuvent appeler
lors de certaines émissions ce qui
revient régulièrement c'est donnez-nous
des moyens pour parvenir à faire aller
des médicamament pour ma grand-mère qui
est malade c'était très très important
il y avait surtout C donc là on a un
retour ce qu'on appelle un pivot vers
l'est un retour vers l'Est d'un point de
vue économique bon et puis enfin
impossible de parler de la situation en
Iran aujourd'hui sans aborder la
question de de la société civile sans
rappeler évoquer évidemment les droits
humain on est près d'un an et demi après
la mort de de Massa mini on va faire le
point ce soir avec vous Tam avant de
faire réagir nos invités vous êtes
demandé où on était justement
aujourd'hui la la situation des des
droits humains en Iran voilà et si on
regarde ce n'est pas brillant alors que
nous abordons aujourd'hui ce sujet les
dernières nouvelles en la matière de
l'Iran c'est la flagélation de RO Mathis
cette jeune militante qui a reçu 74
coups de fouet le 3 janvier dernier pour
atteinte au murs public son crime avoir
publié des photos d'elle sur les réseaux
sociaux sans foulard 74 coup de fouet
c'est aussi la condamnation du chanteur
de pop iranien Meddi yarai pour avoir
critiqué le voile dans une chanson et
avant cela comment ne pas parler
d'armita garawan lycéenne de 16 ans un
mois de coma avant de mourir après avoir
été arrêté dans une station de métro à
théran le 1er octobre face encore et
toujours à la police des murs police qui
comporte pas moins de 2850 surveillants
de hijab dans les transports publics de
la capitale désormais les autorités
elles ont lancé une véritable campagne
d'oppression à l'égard des femmes des
jeunes filles iraniennes et de ceux qui
les défendent ce sont trois exemples qui
illustrent cette situation dont la loi
aussi se fait l'écho puisqu'à l'automne
l'Iran a adopté la loi qui vise à
soutenir la culture de la chasteté et du
hijjab un texte qui a encore durci
lesexantion qui sont encouru par les
femmes qui osent donc défier le régime
oui une loi qui a été largement
condamnée par la communauté
internationale oui 1er septembre le Haut
Commissariat aux Droits de l'Homme
publie d'ailleurs une déclaration pour
critiquer ce qui est alors un projet de
loi les experts parlent je le cite de
forme d'aparille entre les sexes demande
à reconsidérer le texte idem pour le
Comité des droits de l'homme des Nations
Unies là encore un comité d'experts qui
a appelé au mois de novembre à abroger
ce texte sauf sauf que bon benah fait ce
que je dis mais pas ce que je fais l'ONU
n'a pas de leçons à donner en la matière
depuis que son Conseil des droits de
l'homme à ne pas confondre avec le
comité le conseil est constitué de pays
a vu l'un de ces forums au mois de
novembre qui a donc été présidé par
l'Iran on en avait beaucoup parlé à ce
moment-là au mois de décembre également
et bien le chef de la diplomatie
iranienne avait même été convié à Genève
pour s'exprimer sur le futur des droits
humains il n est finalement pas allé
mais ce sont des réunions certes où ne
se prennent pas des grandes décisions
mais la pilule reste durable valler du
coup euh que que que reste-t-il au pays
qui condamne la répression iranienne ben
il reste le prix Nobel de la paix qui a
été décerné à Narjes Mohammadi en 2023
toujours en détention en Iran il reste
les condamnés à mort qui sont parrainés
par exemple par des parlementaires
notamment les Français alors que l'Iran
a battu cette année un triste record en
exécutant plus de 700 personnes en 2023
ben ça pèse pas lourd non ce sont autant
de symboles de notre impuissance mais
des symboles nécessaires j'ai interrogé
sur ce sujet Christian Cambon
ex-président de la commission des
affaires étrangères sur le sujet qui
était en place au moment où lieu toutes
ces actions pour savoir s'il y avait eu
des suites après ces parrainages de
condamnés à mort par exemple sa réponse
elle a été sans surprise c'est non pas
de réponse de l'ambassade iranienne ni
même des autorités et d'ailleurs il ne
s'y attendait pas c'était pas l'objectif
l'objectif c'était avant tout de
continuer d'attirer l'attention de
l'opinion publique alors que si peu
d'information sortent d'Iran imaginez
que pour cette jeune femme dont je
parlais au début qui a reçu 74 coups de
fouet euh et bien on a eu l'information
avec près d'une semaine de retard il
semblerait que même si l'Iran à coup de
répression a réussi à faire taire les
manifestation publiqu il y a toujours un
mouvement souterrain qui continue qui
persiste et des voix aussi qui sélèvent
toujours qui sont courageuses voir
téméraires pour dénoncer la situation on
va regarder un extrait du clip de My
yarai dont je parlais tout à l'heure
avec 74 coups de fois qui l'attendent
sur sa chanson mon voile
Rosarito داره
غروب
میکنه رو سری تو دربیار عطر تو هوا رو خو
میکنه
رو سریو در بیار موهاتو پز پز پز
کن عشق من نترس ب خند به گریه اعتراز
کن
armf où on est la contestation en IR
aujourd'hui sur sur question du voile
bah ce qui est très intéressant c'est
qu'en dépit euh du renforcement de la
police des meurs qui était au départ en
tout cas la raison pour laquel mass a
été tué au main donc de cette même
police de MEUR en dépit euh de
l'aggravation des sanctions pour
quiconque ne porte pas correctement le
voile ne le porte pas on a aujourd'hui
toujours dans les plus grandes villes du
pays de 1/3 à la moitié euh des femmes
qui ne portent plus le voile qui ne le
portent plus qui ont euh franchi euh ce
mur de la de la peur en dépit de tout ce
qu'elle risque en dépit justement des
condamnations pour les f chaque fois
qu'elle sortte de chez elle
effectivement et c'est ça qui est très
intéressant c'est que sur le court terme
oui le régime a gagné en tout cas réussi
à étouffer cette contestation auprès
quand même d'une effroyable répression
551 manifestants tués plus de 11000
arrêtés au moins six qui ont été
condamnés à mort mais autant l'Iran est
extrêmement puissant à l'extérieur de
ses front è et profite des erreurs de
ses rivaux on voit aujourd'hui par
exemple que le 7 octobre a permis à
l'Iran par le biais du Hamas d'obtenir
la suspension de la normalisation entre
l'Iran et l'Arabie Saoudite et plusieurs
diplomates en
privé parle justement d'un véritable
sens politique de l'Iran mais autant à
l'intérieur même de ces frontières
l'Iran est un pays en tout cas le régime
est un pays le régime est contesté et
toujours contesté et que ce n'est pas
parce qu'il n'y a plus de manifestation
euh que la contestation s'est éteind
bien au contraire en en témoigne tout ce
qui était changé encore aujourd'hui sur
les réseaux sociaux en Témo tous les
mouvements tous les mouvements de
désobéissant civiles dans la rue sur les
réseaux sociaux avec justement ces
femmes qui se prennent en photo sans
leur voile en témoigne toutes ces
chansons toutes ces musiques qui sont
créées en faveur de la la contestation
la contestation contre le régime dans
son ensemble et pas seulement pour le
port du voile donc il y a quelque chose
qui a changé en Iran et qui ne reculera
pas il y a un point de non retour qui a
été franchi maintenant il suffit de
regarder la réponse gouvernementale et
des autorités donc islamique à savoir la
répression tousasimut pour comprendre
que ce n'est pas quelque chose qui est
résolu bien au contraire et que à la
moindre étincelle il est très probable
qu'une nouvelle contestation qu'une
nouvelle surtout manifestation éclate à
nouveau même si on on redoute qu'elle
soit à nouveau réprimé dans le sang
d'ailleurs juste pour terminer le prix
sakarov a également été décerné en plus
plus du prix Nobel à des iraniennes les
deux récipients d'air donc au nom de
MASSIN mini les deux récipients d'air
parce que sa famille n'a pas été
autorisé à venir au Parlement européen à
Strasbourg savoir Mercedes shahinkar et
Assou Najafi de militant Irens des
droits de l'homme souligner à quel point
elle se sentait abandonné par la
communauté internationale et notamment
l'Union européenne qui d'après ce
qu'elle voulait elle souhaitait
justement que les Gardiens de la
Révolution qu'elle juge comme les
principaux responsables de la répression
en Iran soit placé sur la liste
européenne des organisations terroristes
ce qui n'est pas arrivé il n av pas eu
de volonté politique au sein de l'Union
européenne pour que cela arrive alors
vous parliez des réseaux sociaux on on
va regarder ces images d'un d'un d'un
marchand de poisson de 70 ans qui ont
aussi beaucoup tourné sur sur les
réseaux sociaux voilà il s'est mis il
s'est mis à danser devant son échop et à
rencontrer un grand succès jusqu'à ce
que la police souhaite l'arrêter et puis
finalement c'est devenu à son corps
défendant une forme de héros Amélie
Chelly est-ce que le mouvement qui a été
engagé dans la société civile même si on
voit toutes les difficultés il vous
paraît irréversible oui bon déjà juste à
titre personnel quand je suis allé la
dernière fois en Iran il y avait pas de
femm qui sortaient sans voile elles
étaient mal voilé souvent mais il y
avait pas là c'est effectivement le cas
il y a beaucoup de femmes qui osent
sortir sans voil pendant très longtemps
on va dire à partir des années 2000 ce
qu'on a observé en Iran c'est qu'on
n'allait pas être dans la répression
individuelle des contrevenances au mœurs
sauf si le ce cette personne là ce ce ce
représentant de l'autorité là en avait
envie c'était un petit peu arbitraire et
puis il y a eu un raidissement non
c'était surtout à partir des années 2000
ça a surtout été ce que j'appelle les
phénomènes de déferl c'est-à-dire dès
qu'il y avait une volonté de contevenir
à des questions liées auxurs en public
pour créer un mouvement qui pourouvait
faire perdre la face au régime c'est que
individuellement on s'intéressait plus
vraiment à l'idée selon laquelle c'est
l'idéologie de la République islamique
qui le dit euh une personne qui
contrevient aux lois islamique met en
péril le salut de l'humanité on était
plus vraiment dans cet état d'esprit là
à partir des années 2000 c'était plutôt
une question de ne pas perdre la face
mais là ils l'ont perdu la face là
clairement j'ai l'impression que on est
dans uneou il y a à la fois une
répression qui est terrible et en même
temps il y a des prises de liberté que
les Iraniennes ne veulent plus du tout
lâcher qui sont encore bien loin de ce
qu' ce à quoi elles aspirent évidemment
mais ça a quand même pas mal évolué je
je n'ai pas souvenir d'une femme portant
ne portant pas le voile alors dans dans
les il y a toutes les villes ne sont pas
les mêmes en Iran il y a des villes où
on est plus religieux que d'autres et où
on mais même dans le nord de téran où on
fait pas forcément très attention à ses
tenues on porte mal le voile tout le
monde le portait néanmoins même si
c'était mal porté là j'ai l'impression
que ça s'est beaucoup élargi juste pour
finir vraiment très rapidement la
réputation internationale de l'Iran elle
a été entachée avec cette affaire là ou
il s'en fiche alors je malheureusement
du côté des régimes je pense s'en fiche
mais ça a été entaché je pense que
d'ailleurs un des éléments qui a conduit
à l'arrêt des négociations sur le
nucléaire iranien de la part des
Occidentaux c'est la répression qui a eu
lieu en Iran bien et ben merci beaucoup
à tous les trois merci Tam c'est la fin
de cette émission merci donc d'y avoir
participé et puis merci à vous de
l'avoir regardé lundi vous retrouverez
Thomas HUG dans ce fauteuil et puis moi
je serai juste à côté à la place de Tam
et puis demain matin on vous donne
rendez-vous sur Public Sénat avec Alain
duamel qui sera l'invité de la matinale
demain à 8h bonne
[Musique]
soirée